Hilary Clinton says her husband
absolutely should not have resigned
following the Monica Lewinsky scandal in
an interview for CBS Sunday morning the
former first lady and presidential
candidate spoke with Tony de copal about
the record number of women running for
office in 2018
she was also asked about her husband's
conduct while President there are people
who look at the incidence of the 90s and
they say a President of the United
States cannot have a consensual
relationship with an intern the power
imbalances too was an adult but let me
ask you this
where's the investigation of the current
incumbent against whom numerous
allegations have been made and which he
dismisses denies and ridicules so there
was an investigation and it as I believe
came out in the right place Tony de
copal is here with more from that
interview Tony good morning you asked
the question I did ask the question it
was a wide-ranging conversation it's
about an hour long conversation and you
know Hillary Clinton knows more than
perhaps anyone about what it's like to
be a woman in politics she's a two-time
presidential candidate and she became in
2016 the first women to win a major
party's nomination we sat down to talk
about sexism politics and why this
year's crop of female candidates may
still feel like they're running uphill
what warnings do you have as we reach
crunch time in the 2018 campaign for the
women who are out there running you just
have to be yourself come hell or high
water you just have to be yourself and
say more about the hell part ya know
sometimes it is so apparent that you are
being judged on your hair your clothes
all of that and you know you look over
at the males running and you know there
are no fashion icons but nobody is
saying I'm not voting for him because he
didn't comb his hair I'm not voting for
him because you know his suit is rumpled
of course even as Hillary Clinton
supports female candidates she holds a
complicated position in the me2 era
remember her husband President Bill
Clinton was accused of multiple acts of
sexual misconduct before becoming
president and was impeached over lives
he told about his relationship with a
White House intern
Clinton stood by his side through all of
that looking back do you wish you had
done things differently in your personal
life in the 90s and if you had do you
think it would have helped you
politically in 2016 it's an easy
question to answer no no on both counts
I did what I thought was right and I
feel very good about that
when you support women now who are
running with their stories of sexual
assault front and center does it make it
more difficult for you to be forward as
a supporter when you have not contended
fully with the accusers in your own life
well no because there was the most
intense comprehensive investigation
people forget that and I don't I
remember it very clearly and in
retrospect do you think bill should have
resigned president clinton should have
resigned in the 90s in the wake of the
Monica Lewinsky scan so it wasn't an
abuse of power no you do not believe he
should have resigned no how do you
contend with members of your own party
now saying he should have that's that's
their right to their opinion but they
were not in the middle of it now Bill
and Hillary Clinton will kick off a
series of speaking engagements together
next month in Las Vegas where I imagine
this may come up yet again now of course
the past never changes people's
perspective on the past tends to change
but it appears in this case Hillary
Clinton's perspective has not even
Monica Lewinsky's perspective has
changed over what she said even you know
a few decades ago yeah you know I asked
her in summary is there a double
standard being applied here and and
Hillary's very quite clear no there's
not or if there is it's one that
benefits the current occupant of the
White House she is so much more than
what her husband did in the Oval Office
she is absolutely and continues to be
defined by that all right thank you Tony
to Coco